the left is feeling a lot of emotions
after president trump's covid diagnosis
they're feeling
a little bit of sympathy just a little
bit they're feeling a lot of happiness
we'll get to that
and mostly what they're feeling is
self-righteousness
jake tapper over at cnn sums up
perfectly
all of the sanctimony many americans are
likely feeling both sympathy and anger
today emotions that don't necessarily
mix well
sympathy for all of those suffering
including president trump
who remains at walter reed medical
center but also
anger because so much so much of all
this pain
could have been avoided so many of us
since march
have been doing everything we can to
preserve the health of not only
ourselves and our families
but our communities our neighbors
you social distancing wearing masks
holding events remotely weddings have
been canceled jobs
lost children are missing out
on in-person education and their ability
to see friends
it's a real crisis it's going to leave
scars the president has been
undermining these efforts expressing
disdain
for health regulations and those who
abide by them the americans who don't
listen to science or medicine who think
masks are too intrusive who pack bars
who willfully risk spreading the virus
you are making it worse for all of us
you are extending how long this pandemic
will last
none of that is true none of that is
true it seems
jake tapper knows even less about
politics
than he does about viruses he just
grates on and on and it's all trump's
fault and it's all the trump supporters
fault
and they've ruined their lives look the
left has
absolutely ruined everyone's education
canceled weddings
stopped seeing grandma they've ruined
everything and it's still not working
because of those trumpers
they are drawing the complete wrong
conclusions from president trump's
diagnosis
and they are making that classic leftist
mistake
which we will get to i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from thursday is from
andrew cooper who says president trump
is termed a racist by his political
opponents
joe biden is termed a racist by his
running mate that's true
that's true look at the sort of things
that were being said
about joe biden not so long ago but now
of course everybody is rallying behind
him
this absolute edifice of lies this
establishment of lies
from the mainstream media hollywood
elected democrats
the bureaucratic government the public
health experts the universities
all of it teaming up to completely
gaslight us on reality the left
could not be drawing more incorrect
conclusions
wronger conclusions from president
trump's co-vid diagnosis trump by the
way
apparently doing great he's scheduled to
be released
from walter reed after just just a few
days today
he has been giving shows of strength the
whole time
he addressed the nation from walter reed
i just didn't want to stay in the white
house i was given that alternative
stay in the white house lock yourself in
don't ever leave don't even go to the
oval office just stay upstairs and enjoy
it
don't see people don't talk to people
and just be done with it
and i can't do that i had to be out
front and
this is america this is the united
states this is the greatest country in
the world this is the most powerful
country in the world i can't be locked
up in a room upstairs
and totally safe and just say
hey whatever happens happens i can't do
that
we have to confront problems as a leader
you have to confront problems there's
never been a great leader that
would have done that so that's where it
is
i'm doing well i want to thank everybody
our first lady is doing very well that's
where it is
leaders have to confront problems and
that's what trump does
it describes his entire presidency it's
not always easy
think about just the issue of china for
decades both parties just
went along with china just go along to
get along
they said ah maybe it's not good in the
long run that we're shipping all of our
jobs overseas but
look there's a little money now it's
easy we don't want to disrupt things we
don't want to disrupt
corporate interest so let's go along
with it what does trump do throws a
wrench in that
same thing with immigration both parties
go along to get along on open borders
immigration
even though that sort of process is
creating human havoc in its wake
it's destroying actually the lives of
people who are trying to come over here
because of
the what they have to deal with to get
into this country and it's of course
weakening the country itself president
trump deals with it head on and he's
doing the same thing with kovitt i also
want to point out there's a lie that's
being told by the media
that president trump was a weak leader
on kovid that he he made the problem
worse you just heard jake tapper say
that
president trump was much more cautious
and much more effective on coronavirus
than his political opponents were
president trump shut down travel from
china the source of the virus
when joe biden said that that was
hysterical xenophobia
joe biden would have kept that border
open would have made the virus
much much worse nancy pelosi at the same
time that president trump was closing
the border with china what was she doing
she was showing up down in chinatown in
san francisco
without a mask and she said famously
come on down to chinatown
absolutely they were not taking it
seriously then president trump cuts off
travel from europe
again he was criticized for that so even
as a matter of
policy by policy how did the two sides
do trump
was much more cautious took this much
more seriously
than the left but that's not even my
point that's not even my issue here
because the virus has been very
different than a lot of people thought
that it would
president trump knows that by the way
he's now gone through the ringer
and he gave an update a second update
from walter reed
the the language he uses to describe
this virus
the only word that i can use for it is
very interesting
it's been a very interesting journey i
learned a lot about covid
i learned it by really going to school
this is the real school
this is in the let's read the book
school and i get it and i understand
it and it's a very interesting thing and
i'm going to be letting you know about
it in the meantime
we love the usa and we love what's
happening thank you
a vaguer statement has never been it's a
very interesting thing and yeah it's
interesting it's not boring i
tell you it's this it's that notice he
didn't say it's terrible it's the
it's the worst disease ever i'm in
tatters
notice he looks pretty strong he looks
okay he was only in that hospital for a
few days now
let's hope and pray that he continues to
get better because obviously for some
people who've had the virus
it's been very serious but for the vast
vast majority of people who have had the
virus
it hasn't been particularly tough for
a huge number of people some some
surveys showing up to 50 percent
they don't even show symptoms or very
very very mild symptoms
and then for over 99 of people who get
the virus they'll recover totally fine
and even president trump who's in a risk
category he's a little bit older
he eats a lot of fast food you can just
see it on the video that was the point
of putting out those videos
he's doing pretty good he looks pretty
strong
i don't know what it is it's maybe
something in his diet you know i have
you know he says that he draws strength
from uh mcdonald's french fries
and he draws strength from not
exercising i have a i guess an analogous
exercise regimen which is i draw a lot
of strength
from wine which is why i love first leaf
first leaf
just picks out magnificent wines and
they give you a totally
reasonable price for it you know you
know the feeling you're sitting at home
you're finishing a glass of wine
just as you're about you're reaching out
to pour another one you realize there's
no backup bottle this is called
novenophobia
this is the fear of running out of wine
well you don't need to deal with that
anymore thanks to first leaf
i get personalized boxes of wine shipped
right to my door here's how you can get
incredible wine without leaving
the comfort of your home very simple you
take a wine quiz
to assess your taste in wine but then
first leaf doesn't always totally
believe you
right because very often people don't
know how to describe their palette so
they'll give you things generally like
you described but maybe they'll throw in
one there that
let's see because you like this maybe
you try this and they did this for me i
i poured out a bottle i said i'm not
gonna like this then i took a sip i said
oh my gosh
turns out that the wine experts over at
first leaf know a little bit more about
wine than i do
then you get you keep giving ratings and
they refine the future shipments really
great stuff
really really high quality wine you can
choose what you want
right in out of your next box first leaf
updates the inventory every month so
you're not going to get bored of
anything like that has a 100
satisfaction guarantee sign up today get
six bottles of wine for only 29.95
plus free shipping go to
tryfirstleaf.com
knowles kwles that is six bottles of
wine for 29.95 that is incredibly
inexpensive dryfirstleaf.com knowles
so important for president trump to show
strength which he did
now the left is attacking him because
there was this huge rally of people
praying for him and cheering him on
right outside the hospital and president
trump just took a quick little
jaunt around in the secret service
vehicle
and they're driving around and he's
waving to the supporters
another very important thing to do
you've got this global pandemic such as
it is
you've got the leader of the free world
has it he has got to show people that
he's okay
that is a very important matter of
statecraft
and so he does that and so cnn accuses
him
of putting the lives of his secret
service agents
in danger doing instead in doing this pr
move to show his supporters that he is
doing all right
is he is putting the lives of secret
service agents
at risk we saw there were at least two
secret service agents in the vehicle
in which the president was riding in
they were wearing those n95 respirators
but that was it that that is not the
kind of protocols that are
happening at the building behind me at
walter reed where we've been told that
the doctors who have to go into the room
with the president to treat him they are
wearing the full suite
of protective gear which includes not
only masks but some kind of a face
shield
it includes gloves it includes
protective equipment on top of their
clothing
so obviously there is some risk here
that the president
is willing to put these secret service
officers secret service agents through
in order to get his public uh facing
objectives
so first off what that guy just said is
a lie
first just the part about the protective
equipment you can look in
at the vehicle at the photo that cnn is
using and you can see
that the secret service agents are
wearing all of that protective equipment
that he says that they're not wearing
you can look it they're wearing some
kind of gown type thing over their suit
you can see the same thing with the
driver so they've got all of this two
agents in that car
second point though i guess this is the
bigger point
does this guy know what the secret
service
is what they do
the entire job of the secret service
is to risk their lives for the president
you have to be willing to take a bullet
for the president of the united states
that is the job now what some people are
saying is there's no reason though
that the c that trump had to take this
ride to wave to his supporters i think
there was a huge
reason i think that he has to show
strength not just to his supporters but
to our adversaries overseas who are
looking very closely right now but even
beyond that
this cnn guy seems to think that the
secrets
when trump is in the hospital the secret
service are nowhere to be found
the secret service are always around the
president
they are always there there is not you
don't get to run away for a little while
and the secret service says okay bye mr
president
we'll pick you up in a few hours they're
always there they're always
already being exposed to this sort of
thing cnn is just very upset that
president trump
is now enduring this virus he's in this
dangerous age group
he's enduring this virus that they have
been fear-mongering us all over
for the past eight months and president
trump is looking
strong and he's dealing with this
head-on
liberals are drawing the complete wrong
conclusions from trump getting covered
the one point they seem to be showing is
and they've been talking about this on
twitter on tv news and all these things
they say now that trump has covid now
finally
maybe his supporters will take this
seriously the people who didn't want to
plunge the entire country into a great
depression and shut down everything
and stop people from going to their
families funerals and stop kids from
going to school and stop elective
surgeries and stop important surgeries
that are going to lead to higher
deaths from things like cancer for
instance because treatments were not
being given
while the hospitals were all locked down
for kovid now maybe those awful people
will take this seriously
it always comes back to the masks you
know they they're so obsessed with the
masks
the magical cloth mask that nobody wears
correctly that
that is going to protect everybody from
the virus
the liberals seem to think i'll just use
the mask as an example but it's an
example
it stands in for all these other
measures too the liberals seem to think
that we oppose the mask rules
because we don't think that we can get
covid19
in reality we oppose the mask rules
because we know
that we're all going to get covet 19.
liberals think that we oppose the
lockdowns and shutting down school and
ruining everybody's life
because we think that we could we could
never get it but it's the opposite of
that
it's that we know that these policies
that they have put into place
are not sufficient to stop a virus
because no policies have ever been
sufficient to stop
a virus because the public health
experts that they are deferring to those
people themselves
are telling us that these things are not
sufficient to stop the virus
dr daniel griffin at columbia just one
public health expert among many but in a
left-wing outlet he admitted this he
told npr he said
in the studies masks fail
now you're not allowed to say that now
you're not allowed to say that the masks
are not particularly effective
at stopping the virus but listen to why
listen to why
he says in the studies masks fail
people don't use them correctly they
touch the front of it
they adjust it they push it down i mean
you can see you you know this all the
time probably from your personal life
how often are you washing your masks
probably are you watching them every day
are you washing them twice a day or you
probably not for a lot of people
they have the same dirty mask they shove
it in their pocket when they walk into a
restaurant
they have to put it on when you use a
mask that way when you're touching your
face when you're actually from dr fauci
early on in the
in when he was telling people at that
point not to wear masks because masks
he said were useless against the virus
this is before he changed his mind and
said people should wear masks
but he said that the reason is that you
put the mask on and all of a sudden
you're touching your face a lot more
which actually could undermine the the
effectiveness
of the masks so i'm i'm willing to say
just for the sake of argument let's say
that that the masks could have
a 100 effective rate they don't no study
shows they have 100 effective rate not
even close
but let's just say that they did for the
sake of argument
my argument against the masks is not a
scientific argument it's a political
argument
because in order for that 100 effective
rate to to matter
people have to use the masks correctly
which they will not they simply won't
and jake tapper can cry on cnn all he
wants about the mean old republicans who
aren't wearing their masks right by the
way a lot of democrats aren't wearing
their masks right either
but regardless if your
policy requires people to behave
100 perfectly all of the time that's not
much of a policy at all
that policy this is the classic leftist
mistake
is they're ignoring human nature they
think that they can overcome
human nature if the masks only work in
this utopian world
then the masks don't work and that's
exactly what this this doctor from
colombia is telling npr
the the masks fail in the studies sure
maybe it's
because of because humans aren't using
it correctly but guess what
the policies are for humans dr fauci
admitted the same
principle when it come beyond the masks
when it comes to the vaccines
and you know we've all been we've all
been waiting on this vaccine
we went from flattened the curve to find
a cure to find a vaccine we've all been
waiting on this a long time
and it has destroyed our economy a lot
of people are making a lot less money
now than they used to and that's why
they've got to switch over to puretalk
because you're probably over
overpaying for your cell phone coverage
if your cell phone plan
is with verizon att
t-mobile you are paying way too much for
the exact same coverage you would be
getting right now with pure talk
now i know what you heard you just heard
me say you're paying too much
for similar coverage that you would get
with pure talk that's not what i said
what did i say i said the exact same
coverage
same towers same networks but you're
paying twice as much
look at your cell phone bill where it
shows the data usage the average person
who switches to pure talk
is using less than four gigs of data per
month but the big carriers what are they
doing they're charging you for unlimited
data
it's like paying for an entire row on an
airplane but then you only need one seat
why would you do that
that is how pure talk saves the average
customer over four hundred dollars per
year
on their wireless service unlimited talk
text and two gigs of data you know how
much you get that for
20 bucks a month 20 bucks a month
unbelievable
people who are switching to pure talk
are saying it is the easiest decision
that you will make all day head on over
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say michael knowles
m-i-c-h-a-e-l canada wlas like beyonce
when you do you will save fifty percent
off your first month dial pound
two five zero say keyword michael
knowles pure talk simply
smarter wireless how is that for a
segway that
i hate to point it out but that was a
great segue
forget about those masks okay just put
the masks aside for a second turn to the
vaccines
dr fauci was being interviewed by cnn he
was asked about the effectiveness of the
vaccine because when we're talking now
now we sound like we're just trying to
find a cure and then finally when we
have a cure then we can reopen the
country
even though that's a utopian quest in
and of itself
but we have this idea that the vaccine
is going to solve everything vaccines
are not 100 effective
actually when we're talking about this
vaccine even if we got super duper lucky
we found the greatest vaccine
you're still talking about 70
effectiveness
i doubt seriously that any vaccine will
ever be
100 protected the best we've ever done
is measles which is 97 to 98
effective um oh that would be wonderful
if we get there i don't think we will
i would settle for a 70 75 percent
effective vaccine because that would
bring you to that level of would be
herd immunity level okay well that
sounds pretty good
if we could look i mean you're still
saying 30 percent of people
are gonna are they're gonna get this
vaccine and it's not gonna be effective
and they're gonna get covet and
god forbid what happens so 30 that's a
lot of people right
however then you could if you get to 70
75 percent then you're at that
herd immunity level you know that that
hurt immunity is when
the virus has already run through the
population and so the population then is
stronger and more resilient against it
some countries who had intelligent
policies on covet early on
like sweden for example pursued that
idea they said we're not going to weaken
our immunities
we're not going to just hide away in a
purell bubble for the next
year of our lives we're going to go out
and treat this like we treat other
viruses
and we'll see what happens they were
told that the whole country was going to
get
absolutely knocked down by the virus
actually they're doing
quite well and we'll see how they do
into the future because obviously once
you achieve that
goal early on that has better effects
down the line but okay 70 75 percent you
get to that hurt immunity that's great
so we'll get the vaccine we'll get the
70 75 percent we get the herd immunity
then we're all good right
fauci says not so fast if only
say 70 75 of americans are willing to
get the vaccine
and it's only say i think you just said
70 75
effective is that going to get us to
hurt immunity um
unlikely and that's one of the reasons
why we have to make sure we engage the
community
as we're doing now to get community
people to help us
for people to understand that we are
doing everything we can to show that
it's safe and that it's effective
and it's for the good of them as
individuals
and in society to take the vaccine so we
have a lot of work to do because as you
well know
we've spoken about this intensively in
the past there is a general anti-science
anti-authority anti-vaccine
feeling among some people in this
country
an alarmingly large percentage of people
relatively speaking
i think there's an anti-politics problem
that's going on among the public health
experts
i think i think i don't think it's the
anti-science problem among the people i
think it's the anti-politics
it's the anti-philosophical it's the
anti-human nature
problem that's going on in our
scientific community
he says 70 75 effective vaccine we've
got herd immunity
so the woman says okay but what if some
people don't take the vaccine
he goes oh yeah well then we're not
going to get hurt immunity yeah she goes
what if only 70 75 percent of people
take the vaccine that's only 70 75
effective because yeah then we're not
going to get hurt immunity
so then we're not going to get hurt
immunity buddy that's how it works
i i get it in your ideal utopian world
you could force everybody to get the
vaccine
and then you get 100 use of it and then
you get 70 75 then you got hurt immunity
but we're not living in that world we
don't have a country where you can just
force people who don't want to take a
vaccine
to take it at least at least not in this
particular case
right so so then what
so then it doesn't work so then i know
people are castigated for saying the
vaccine won't be as effective as they're
promising for saying the masks won't be
as effective as they're promising
it's not because of any scientific claim
it's a political claim
human nature has something to say here
no scientist had ever proposed some
policy that was going to stop the virus
okay you remember the point of the
lockdowns was
flatten the curve so that we don't
overwhelm the hospitals we never came
close to overwhelming the hospitals
the javits center emergency hospital in
new york was mostly empty the
hospital ship that was sent to new york
by the federal government was sent home
same thing happened in california good
we didn't we didn't
but flattening the curve doesn't reduce
the number of cases the point of this is
there are limits to politics there is no
magical policy that is going to stop the
virus in its tracks or stop the flu
or stop the common cold or stop anything
else every utopian policy in history
has been much worse much worse than the
disease
that it promised to cure and
the the the left because they can't get
past human nature
because they keep running up against
this they say but people aren't doing
what i want them to do
they're not behaving perfectly mind you
these leftists
don't behave perfectly themselves do
they even
notice the the these left wingers are
pretending that if trump had just worn
the mask no one would get the virus
a lot of left wingers who have worn the
mask have gotten the virus now they
would blame other people to say well
because it's other people aren't wearing
the mask
well because other people haven't locked
down well because other people went to
work okay fine
sure reality
contradicted your theory reality
contradicted your model
because human nature is human nature and
the left doesn't like human nature so
now they're openly wishing that
president trump
would die now this is this is what
happens when you've got people
on the left who are just stuck in their
own ideologies one thing that can kind
of crack you out of your own ideology
is taking a cold hard look at business
which is why i would recommend
right now checking out the expert
ownership course that the ben brothers
and jeremy boring and lots of other
people
are putting through there are only two
days left to get
a discounted ticket to expert ownership
live a virtual conference october 21st
and 22nd featuring world-renowned
leaders like john maxwell
the founders of duck commander and
otterbox
the benham brothers and our personal
favorite jeremy boring
this two-day virtual conference will set
you up with the skills you need to lead
through crisis
you'll hear stories about the challenges
of startup journeys the tough times that
come with any company
and how these individuals pushed through
failure to come out successful on the
other side
i really like this idea because i mean
jeremy will tell the story just of the
daily wire
we've gone through some tough times here
at the daily wire jeremy let us through
and there's nothing that will smack down
uh theory
quite like going through possible
failure as a company all business
leaders
have to deal with failures but it forces
you
to change your theories and it's very
important because then you can be
successful
this is a great lineup we would love to
have you join today
for only 97 go to expert ownership live
dot com slash knowles
go there in the next 48 hours to
register
and you'll get to see jeremy how about
that expert ownership live dot com slash
knowles for 97
only today and tomorrow with an
opportunity to purchase a second ticket
for a friend of 50
off expert ownership live.com knowles to
secure your spot
democrats now openly wishing that trump
dies zara rahim
a former obama official who also worked
on clinton's presidential campaign
hillary not bill she uh tweets out
after the president was diagnosed quote
it's been against my moral identity to
tweet this for the past four years but
i hope he dies and then she's got little
stars around the dyes
daiso imagine saying that imagine saying
that about a fellow person
and this is not just some low-level
staffer right this is
an obama administration official and a
high-level clinton presidential official
imagine if any republican said this
about a democrat
about that about the democratic
president about barack obama can you
imagine be wall-to-wall coverage this
probably your only hearing on this show
max berger former staffer for elizabeth
warren
i can't think of anything more
distasteful than wishing death upon
another human
except maybe causing preventable mass
death because you don't want to damage
the stock market
or your re-election chances all jokes
aside i hope the president injects
himself with bleach
it's a liz warren staffer by the way
when these people say that trump has
made the virus worse and he caused
preventable mass death and all this
ask him how ask those people how did he
do that what did he do
as far as i can tell people are mostly
trying their best
in this country even the governors and
the mayors they're trying their best
some have
way overreacted but they're trying their
best to protect public health
and most of the policy decisions are
defensible
with one exception andrew cuomo in new
york sending sick people into nursing
homes
that one is absolutely indefensible
andrew cuomo the democratic governor
darling of the democratic party
does have to come to account for that
other than that
i don't see any example anywhere in the
country but they're convinced trump is
killing people
so what does this mean for trump well
there's a very
interesting poll that is just out the
left is celebrating this poll but they
shouldn't they shouldn't get too cocky
because they only read the headline they
didn't read
what it really means this poll could be
very very good news for president trump
and it's reminding me of that 2016
election when those polls
allegedly looked so good for hillary
clinton we'll get to what those polls
mean
in just a second we will get to a
ridiculous attack by a fox news reporter
of all people
on the president using the same race
hustling trash that we usually get from
the left
but in case you didn't get enough
politics last week
this coming wednesday october 7th will
be the vice presidential debate between
mike pence and kamala harris
daily wire's matt walsh will be live
reacting to the debate as part of a
special edition of all access live
members can join matt wednesday night at
8 30 eastern 5 30 pacific at
dailywire.com
to live chat with him on the live stream
and in the comments if you are not part
of daily wire already
join now as an all access member get 20
off the code debate so you can watch all
of our upcoming debate coverage live at
dailywire.com
apple tv or the roku app and join
us on all access live every night for
online and live stream discussions
and you get not just one but two leftist
tears tumblers
head on over wednesday october 7th 8 30
eastern 5 30 pacific get 20 off all
access with code debate when you sign up
today we'll be right back with a lot
more
a new nbc news wall street journal poll
shows that biden is up 14
points nationally uh oh
uh oh i don't like that 53-39 biden up
14 points nationally in early october
but i i had deja vu i don't know what it
was reading that number i got deja vu
so i took a look molly hemingway posted
this
this is from october 5th no i'm sorry
october 10th
2016. uh this was
posted at cbs news poll hillary clinton
leads donald trump by 14 points
nationally
the same number at the same time
and do you know what that number meant
in 2016
that number and a buck 50 would get you
a cup of coffee that number was
absolutely worthless
because even though hillary she was
supposed to have the huge lead
she didn't and she lost very often the
left will
use polls to demoralize republicans and
try to convince them that it's not even
worth showing up to vote
because we've already lost that's what
they did in 2016 and they were wrong
but this poll is a little more
interesting than that because it shows
biden up 14 points nationally
but it shows trump gaining in the key
swing states
so he's losing ground nationally but
he's gaining in the swing states
the national poll doesn't matter
this election is not held at the
national level it's held at the state
level
and then you win the states and you get
the electors and then
you tally those up and you see who wins
all that matters are those swing states
it doesn't matter how many people in
california and new york don't like trump
the democrats are already going to win
those states so you look at those swing
states florida pennsylvania trump is
gaining
very very good news democrats are very
very
upset about this the left-wing edifice
is very upset about this
the blob the establishment so they go
back to their favorite old
strategy they go back to race hustling
this time i don't know what is going on
at fox but this was a fox news reporter
john roberts
who approached the press secretary
kaylee mcinnady
and demanded that president trump
condemn
white supremacy i'd like to ask you for
a definitive
and declarative statement without
ambiguity
or deflection as the person who speaks
for the president
does the president denounce white
supremacism
and groups that espouse it in all their
forms
this has been answered yesterday by the
president himself the day before by the
president himself on the debate stage
the president was asked this he said
sure three times
yesterday he was point blank blink asked
do you
uh denounce white supremacy and he said
i've always denounced any form
of that i can go back and read for you
um in august 2019 and one voice our
nation must condemn racism
bigotry and white supremacy in august of
2017
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name are criminals
and thugs including the kkk neo-nazis
white supremacists and other hate groups
i have an entire list of these quotes
that i can go through with you
he is condemned white's privacy more
than any president in modern history
just to clear it up this morning can you
naming it make a declarative statement
that you deny that the president
denounces it i just did
uh the president has denounced this
repeatedly
wow that is the most hack
journalism i have ever seen and it
wasn't cnn and it wasn't msnbc
that was a fox news guy who like
a complete empty suit
hack says does the president condem
white supremacy she goes yeah
i'm gonna read you a tenth of the times
he's condemned it
to that we played a montage just a short
montage on our show on thursday
so yeah i think it's pretty clear he's
condemned white supremacy
dozens and dozens of times and he goes
yes but but are you willing to
to just to clarify or declare what to
clarify
are you kidding me he's done it dozens
of times she just read it to you
yes but you're not you're just you're
reading old quotes
but i want you to do it now do it now do
say what i want you to say
dance monkey dance that's what the left
is telling you that's why i just reject
the question
you know we've done shows it's funny we
did a show a little while ago why is
racism wrong because you hear so much
nonsense about racism that you forget
why racism racism is wrong because it's
an offense against human dignity
that's it very simple that's it okay we
got it good flip that away
now you know why racism is wrong you
don't need to constantly
be reciting these things the reason that
the left does this
is to make you say what they want you to
say
it's not about the content of what
you're saying it's about the act of them
imposing that on you it's
a similar question would be uh kaylee
is the president willing to say that he
no longer beats his wife um
john the president does not has never
beat his wife he does not no
kaylee you're deflecting can the
president please definitively say
that he no longer beats his wife and
by by accepting that premise that you
somehow
have to condemn white supremacy that you
somehow are implicated in white
supremacy or whatever whatever the new
phrase is
bigotry then you have given the left
that point and kaylee handled it
wonderfully
and this guy i mean just absolutely
pathetic and then he goes on fox news
later
and does some more grandstanding he's
like little mini jim acosta over here
take a listen to his temper tantrum
for all of you on twitter who were
hammering me for answering that quote
for asking that question i don't care
because it's a question that needs to be
asked and clearly
the president's republican colleagues a
mile away from here
are looking for an answer for it too so
stop deflecting
stop blaming the media
i'm tired of it all right john
that john roberts is tired of it i'm
tired of it i'm
i'm tired it's a question that needs to
be asked it's only been asked seven
million times and he's answered it
clearly every single time
i'm not stop it stop being so mean to
the media we're trying to destroy this
president and lie about him and you're
not letting us kaylee
what ridiculous trash by the way by the
way president trump asked to do this
again and again and again
he goes on sean hannity's show he called
in and
he was asked do you condemn white
supremacy he goes yes i condemn white
supremacy he went even so far
that he condemned the proud boys and
people are reacting
in a mixed way to his condemnation of
the proud boys
if you listen carefully though it's kind
of funny i have to say i've said it many
times and let me be clear again i
condemn the kkk
i condemn all white supremacists i
condemn the
proud boys i don't know much about the
proud boys almost nothing but i condemn
that
but he should condemn also antifa
antifa is a horrible group of people
they kill people
they what they do to people and they're
causing insurrection they're causing
riots he doesn't want to do that but the
press doesn't go after him and that's a
really bad group of people
but i condemn them and if i can if i say
it a hundred
if i say it a hundred times it won't be
enough because it's fake news
true that is it if he says it a hundred
times it won't be enough because it's
fake news not just the story right that
the issue with fake news is not just
that they run fake stories
it's that they are not the news john
roberts is not a reporter
john roberts is a hack operative who is
it's very clear i didn't i didn't follow
the guy very closely before
but to see that ridiculous performance
that vaudevillian performance there
you just realize oh this guy is not
interested in the news or the story he's
just
putting on a show and trying to give the
democrats a point
that's what makes it fake news so trump
calls in he says yeah i condem
white supremacists and the kkk and the
proud boys
now we know the proud boys aren't white
supremacists we covered this on the show
on thursday just by definition because
their leader is a black cuban guy
so he's a very confused white
supremacist if he's a white supremacist
and the proud boys said explicitly in
the statement we condemn
racism and fascism and communism and
socialism
much more than you can say about antifa
or blm by the way who openly embrace
socialism and communism
and who embrace a form of racism
and who dress up like fascists right so
it's actually the the proud boy's
not analogous at all but in trump's
condemnation here
is yeah i can i condemn this guy condemn
that guy and i can tell the brad boys i
don't know who the proud boys are but
i'm told i have to condemn them so i
condemn them
it's a little you know it's a little bit
clever it's a little too clever by half
i don't know
that i would have condemned them in that
i would have said i don't know who the
proud boys are
i don't i don't follow them they it
doesn't seem like they're white
supremacists to me like
i would question the premise but then
the headline of course would be
president trump refuses to condemn the
proud boys
so he got his point in a little bit the
back way he goes i
totally condemn the proud boys i have no
idea who they are but yeah you uh
okay fine will he condemn antifa so he
deprives them of that headline but of
course
biden is not going to condemn antifa now
in terms of white supremacy what is the
state of things we're being told that
there are racial
hate crimes all over the place and you
know black lives are being
hunted down and lebron james says he
can't leave his home without being
hunted down right
in reality that's not true a lot of it
is a hoax
madison wisconsin there was a hate crime
investigation was pretty big
it had been making the rounds about this
18 year old biracial woman
who said that she was attacked by a
group of four white men
who threw flammable liquid on her and
set her on fire and
screamed racial slurs at her and it
didn't happen
none of it happened they investigated it
they found no evidence that it happened
now the family is saying okay well you
know please respect our privacy at this
time because it was obviously completely
fake which
most people suspected from the beginning
because there wasn't a lot of evidence
from the beginning
so that is a racial hate crime hoax
you're not going to hear about it it
will not be in the mainstream media
there's another racial hate crime
issue going on over at ohio state
university
ohio state university the
university has to report when there are
these kind of safety incidents on campus
so they send out an email and it says
that a guy a white guy was walking on
the street
and a black guy called him a racial slur
then they started speaking
and then the black guy comes over and
punches him in the head
and then the white guy runs away so he
just they post about this
you know if you if you're in college or
you're going to college you often will
get these emails from the chief of
police saying say okay there was this
incident just letting you know don't go
to this area right
two other students had a similar report
they reported a similar incident one was
that a black female in an off-campus
area pulls up next to the victims
screams a racial slur at them the
students ignore the driver
then she followed them then she got out
of her car she attacked a female osu
student
and a black male who police believe is
the same black guy who punched the white
guy in the face
attacked the other the other male
student there so just a few of these
incidents right
the students are protesting because
they're obviously they care so much
about racial justice but they're not
protesting over the incident
they're protesting that the incident was
reported because they're saying that by
reporting
on the racial hate crime that is a ra
that is in itself racial bigotry against
black people so if you report on a crime
where a black guy yells a racial slur to
white guy and punches him
if you report on that then actually you
are committing violence against black
people somehow
they write the details of this incident
were shared
in osu's public safety notice and do not
meet the legal definition of a hate
crime
i think they do to refer to it as such
solely because the alleged perpetrators
used a racial slur is illogical
racial slurs referring to white people
are not based on
a history of violence and oppression
towards white people
using this slur does not have the same
violent racist implications
as a white person saying the n-word for
example nor does this make this incident
a hate crime
so long and short of that if you want to
get through that gobbledygook is that
uh black people can't be racist against
white people that's the conclusion you
say well what if they're
but what if they're being racist against
white people you say no they're not
they're not la la la
right it's my my theory is more
important than your reality that's what
they say
while we're talking about racial
grievance we do have to mention before
we go
some gender grievance too the united
nations
posted a real a a real magnificent
tweet the other day this was a work of
art
in the ridiculous leftist twitter game
un women which is a separate account
tweets out
how to not be a man splainer you know a
mansplainer
they say you can avoid being a
mansplainer by asking yourself
these questions did she indicate any
desire to hear this information
is it possible that she knows more about
this topic than i do
did i read the room before starting to
speak
did i and then it gives the definition
of mansplaining
i cannot wait to mansplain to these
people
how we defunded this stupid organization
i am going to be so excited
if i ever have any uh degree of
political influence in this area where i
can deal with the un
i am going to build the most beautiful
waterfront condominiums there well maybe
we'll we'll we'll lease out the trump
name it'll be nice big trump luxury
condominiums
because surely that would do more good
for the world than this stupid
organization the united nations which
accomplishes
nothing good lots of bad things wastes a
lot of time
and grievance mongers and the united
nations itself
is part of this problem we've been
talking about all day this problem of
the perfect utopian theory coming up
against the reality because the u.n in
theory what you get all the nations of
the world to come together
and we deliberate and we all figure out
how to live together in kumbayan we all
live in peace
in reality what the u.n does is empowers
the worst people in the world
it puts the worst regimes on earth that
slaughter their own people
puts them on the human rights council it
gets all of these awful p
it invites the worst tin pot dictators
in the world to come to the united
states we pay for most of the thing
and or at least the lion's share of the
thing and they criticize america
why do we do that because the people who
establish the united nations
are the same people who think we can
overcome human nature we can
i mean this is the progressive project
right the kind of more conservative
and traditional idea is that human
nature is fixed it's not changing
there are certain laws of the universe
and we need to
govern ourselves in accordance with that
that's what the entire federalist papers
is about
then progressivism comes in and says oh
forget all that that was all written in
the age of newton where we thought there
were eternal truths and fixed laws but
we're in the age of darwin where we know
everything's evolving
and there's no fixed human nature we can
evolve toward utopia
and that's what they they think they're
going to do and they're going to make
you evolve toward utopia damn it
they're going to make you evolve toward
utopia or you are going to die trying
because sometimes you got to crack a few
eggs to make an omelet
i think that's where a lot of this
rancor comes from
they're going after everybody they're
going after melania for goodness sakes
did you hear how they're going after
melania
they found a secret tape some some woman
betrays her
friend melania and releases tapes of
phone calls that they've had
in which melania is sort of venting
about the negative press that she gets
and how she's very unfairly criticized
she leaks it
plays it on cnn they say i'm complicit
i'm the same like him i support him i
don't say enough i don't do enough
no where i am that i put i'm
working like a ass my ass i know
christmas stuff that you know who gives
a [ __ ]
about christmas stuff and decoration but
i need to do it right
yeah but imagine 100 you have no choice
and okay and then i do it and i say that
i'm working on christmas uh planning for
the christmas
and they said oh what about the children
that they were separated
give me a break
where they were saying anything when
obama did that i know
i cannot go i i was trying
to get the kid reunited with the mom i
didn't have a chance needs to go through
the process and through the law
i love her i love her i would
i would charge into battle for that
woman she is
so great she's so elegant she's funny
apparently too didn't realize that
i love that thing that i'm doing they're
criticizing me with the christmas
decorations who gives
come on the christmas i'm doing my best
and it's true she's being completely
unfairly criticized they're accusing her
of
separating children or whatever they go
after trump for
for an obama era policy actually was a
policy was used under obama
it actually goes all the way back to
bill clinton's administration but you
never heard peep about it
until donald trump comes around and they
say all sorts of horrible things about
this woman
and now they're hoping that she and her
husband die at least
they're explicitly saying they want her
husband to die
these are these are big democrat
staffers saying that
isn't it so funny that the left which
talks about
how they just want to save humanity they
love humanity the virus they're going to
stop the virus
and save mankind while they're wishing
for the salvation of humanity they're
wishing for the death of individual
humans that's so weird
that's that's what they always do they
want to save the world from global
warming they want to save the world from
this they want to save the world from
that
humanity but not individual humans
they hate individual humans very often
as you see from what they're tweeting at
the president
sort of things they're doing to
individual republicans
and they they hate those individual
humans because they hate human nature
humanity in the abstract they like very
much but that humanity has nothing to do
with
humans because it ignores human nature
and their politics ignores human nature
and they get more and more frustrated as
their utopian schemes don't work because
utopia means
no place at all you know dopey a place
no place it doesn't exist and they are
going to keep
banging their heads against the wall
trying to make their manifestos and
their ideologies work
and human nature is going to remain the
same stubborn
and they are going to get angrier and
angrier and angrier we were hoping
they could draw some right conclusions
from president trump's diagnosis
but not at all can't let reality get in
the way of the theory that's our show
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wodowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there